vous savez le 21e siècle c'est un truc
qui est très étrange les gens rêvent de
mal comprendre ce que vous dites mais
quand un noir est insulté c'est
l'humanité toute entière que ça concerne
je dis rien d'autre le racisme est un
fléau qui concerne tout le monde
vous savez un jour j'étais dans un über
il ya une altercation entre mon
chauffeur et un restaurateur le
restaurateur l'a traité de sale [ __ ] on
fait un truc équivalent je ne savais
plus maître de honte de honte le noir
dans la sphère il était victime
il est pas humilier c'est humiliant pour
celui qui insulte et si vous voulez si
vous coloré la lutte contre le racisme
vous rétablissez de manière paradoxale
une forme de ségrégation c'est-à-dire il
ya les gens qui serait concerné et les
autres comme le racisme est un problème
humain qui concerne toute l'humanité il
est hors de question que parce que on
est dans une couleur donnée on doive
s'arroger ce combat à ce moment là on
crée si vous voulez des alvéoles dans la
société
les noirs sont concessions concernées
par le racisme les juifs par
l'antisémitisme
les nains par l'anti nanisme et ses
essais contre zack faut se battre si
vous voulez il est hors de question que
dans cette société
celui qui est concerné dans sa chair
personnellement et une sorte de
passe-droit d'indignation par rapport
aux autres parties se seraient misérable
d'être un être humain dans ces
conditions est-ce que la réponse de la
droite où vous avez vous fait réagir et
réveillé juste un petit souci sur le
fond y'a pas de problème
yann moix a raison le racisme et l
affaire de tous d'ailleurs du temps de
l'apartheid
ceux qui luttaient contre l'apartheid
était aussi bien noir que blanc sud
africain ou pas là où il ya peut-être
une imprécision de vocabulaire c'est que
tu aurais dû dire certaines associations
semaine et terre c'est la paix mais
c'est ce que j'ai dit les noirs essaye
de nommer ses sensations communales
auront larié ça éric ses palaces et un
peu maladroit parce que c'est
saucissonné mais on parlait justement
des minorités et vous et cyril j'y
réfléchis sort de déboulonner les
statues extra pourquoi pas déboulonné et
tagué colbert pourquoi pas mais il y
aurait peut-être quelque chose de plus
intelligent
ce serait d'aller poser des fleurs
devant le tombeau de montesquieu qui
était un blanc qui a écrit les plus
belles choses contre le racisme malek
délégués voulaient rajustement je peux
être que je pense qu'on vit dans le même
mondial moi je pense que tout militant
de la lutte antiraciste un rêve
justement que ce soit la lutte de chacun
bien sûr mais
je je quand je dis les noirs veulent
s'approprier cette lutte antiraciste moi
je ne partage pas je ne comprends pas du
tout grave si tu prends pas dans cette
journée-là penses tu confonds pas que le
racisme est le problème de tout le monde
et pas simplement on est bien d'accord
les cantines désolé mais quand tu me dis
que la victime n'ait pas humilier moi
aussi ça me samsam jamais ça me pose
problème et de mal on l'a faut que tu
comprennes quelque chose de très clair
en quoi quelqu'un qui se fait traiter de
sale [ __ ] et en noir est humilié c'est
humiliant pour celui qui profère cette
insulte l'être humain s'humilie et sa
vie ni en imaginant une fraction de
seconde comme on l'a cru dans les
siècles passés que le noir était une
espèce inférieur c'est très grave
moi quand un blanc insulte un noir tout
d'un coup je me souviens je suis blanc
sinon j'y pense jamais exactement comme
les noirs ne s'en souviennent que quand
on leur dit qu'ils sont des sales [ __ ]
mais je veux dire quand je vois
quelqu'un qui insulte un noir j'ai honte
d'être un être humain je préfère être un
chat dans ces moments là et je ne vois
aucune différence entre les noirs et les
blancs et surtout pas au moment de se
battre outre leur assise c'est alors le
pays un truc qui va pas et le racisme
anti blanc ça existe pas alors
maintenant c'est une question c'est ce
qu'assure ce sur quoi il sait déjà c'est
énorme à l'onf il préfère jeanine ondulé
sur le racisme anti blanc n'entend pas
lâcher du cher je vais te dire non je
alors c'est maintenant et non une carte
on en a bien battu mais pas m'atteindre
est donc déjà le racisme anti blanc
n'existe pas car elle ne supporte pas
qu'on fasse une symétrie d'accord entre
le racisme envers les noirs l'heure si
ce montant vers les blancs pour
historique parce que historiquement les
noirs ont été à villy martyrisé humilier
pendant des millénaires
alors que les blancs ne l'ont pas été
pensé pour les dons sur sa sur ça et non
sans peiner pour leur grade
d'accord mais c'est pas pour effet de
porter la cour le racisme est un hameau
qui étaient développés qui a été raffiné
qui a été définie pour mesurer au
combien sur cette planète
les gens de couleur été humilié par les
blancs c'est comme ça qu'ils timo
logiquement le racisme et n'est vous ne
voulez pas quand même utilisé le même
mot pour prendre un coup leur ticket
il n'y a pas de sens et plusieurs vols à
la même chose pour une vérité en blanc
et qu'on te traite de sale blanc mais
pour moi c'est un pansement raciste le
sommet asiatique contre tête de
saladiers atik c'est un propos raciste
il n'y a pas de racisme anti-blancs cas
du racisme anti asiatique etc et tous
les racismes doivent être confondus
doivent être combattus de la même façon
par tout le monde et c'est là où je te
rejoins personne n'a le monopole de la
lutte contre le racisme c'est pas parce
qu'on est noirs qu'on n'est plus
habilité à lutter contre le racisme mais
ne nie pas ce phénomène de racisme anti
blanc qui existent jeune ami alex est
violent aujourd'hui on voit moins de
gens se faire traiter de sale blanc je
suis désolé bayrou et son nom mais ça il
y en a je suis désolé okada les
conséquences sociales ne sont pas les
mêmes c'est à dire que quand on parle de
racisme on parle d'un système qui n'est
pas uniquement qui ne réside pas
uniquement dans des interactions
individuelles étant des insultes donc ça
veut dire que être blanc aujourd'hui
heureusement en france n'est pas un
désavantage
oui on appelle de risque d'être risquée
sur le marché du travail si ça laisse en
fait ça peut l'être lors du gdc se
serait classé que 100 des droits moi je
te renvoie aux études des nations unies
sont des réalités qui sont donc bien sûr
regardez celle d'origine maghrébine
c'est quelque chose qui est très connu
qui monte depuis plusieurs décennies je
pense que tu peux pas raisonnablement
mais je retrouve le jeu c'est pareil je
voulais finir dès lors vous pouvez pas
nier qu'il ya des chiffres qui montrent
bien de rien car plus de difficultés
pour des personnes de couleur des
personnes maghrébine des personnes de
confession juive pour trouver du travail
que pour d'autres je suis désolé ou pour
un appartement des tests ici pour louer
un appartement quand on s'appelait mehdi
ou quand on s'appelait jean jacques mars
plus on remettra ça plombe amplifiera le
phénomène il faudrait pas le dire mais
non mais je sais que ces bornes en
réalité of arcade
oui non séparés mais bien sûr
c'est fini rockets alors bon déjà c'est
pas parce qu'on le répète que ça va se
multiplier au contraire le répéter c'est
éveiller les consciences silence y ait
une cause n'a jamais aidé ce qui
aujourd'hui par exemple je peux faire je
peux faire un amalgame avec la question
du féminisme si on parle autant
aujourd'hui des féminicides c'est parce
que les associations féministes ont fait
le décompte des femmes qui mouraient
chaque jour si on ne l'est pas par les
ignorer pen elle même c'est comme ce que
vous lisez un instant il ya des chiffres
à l'appui ils ont dit pas ça dans le
fond c'est pas une honte quand là c'est
vraiment documenté il ya des chiffres
aussi bordeaux dit ce qui m'intéresse et
je pense que la différence avec ce que
tu as dit ici avant-hier c'est que tu as
dit les noirs veulent avoir le monopole
de la i30 hier à 58,2 les noirs tu
parles de tous les noirs comme d'un
groupe monolithique qui obéissent le tc
vous le mot laissé à sa fête c'est donc
du coup c'est vrai que ça ça prête à
confusion
moi ce que je ne comprends pas dans ce
que tu dis c'est pourquoi tu
reprocherait à nous simplement de
s'intéresser à leur cause
moi je pense que la question parce que
c'est normal que quand on est concerné
par une cause on soit davantage
mobilisés moi je suis aussi engagé dans
le pas sur cela c'est ce qui me plaît
mais majoritairement des femmes
eh bien il faut le reprocher aux gens
qui ne sont pas avec nous s'est précisée
sur moi quand je vais marcher dans la
rue pour des luttes féministes
il ya là j'aurais clairement des femmes
mais tous mais c'est c'est pas bien on
sert justement pour moi le cancer de la
société française que chacun ne se bat
que pour un vin et barrès absolue dans
lequel il est impliqué intimement et
personnellement et c'est précisément ce
matin les gens d'autres causes mais ça y
est on laissera sismologie et
élargissent le speck mais là on va
écouter la gamme
oui c'est ça tout le paradoxe je pense
de yann moix dans ses déclarations
c'est que dans le fond j'ai l'impression
qu'on fait l'effort de vraiment
comprendre ce que tu veux dire que tu
exprimes une idée tout à fait louable
dans un désir de vivre ensemble profond
mais que tu as cette manière de savoir
créer la polémique de savoir utiliser
les mots à bon escient quand il dit que
tu n'es pas compris je pense que c'est
que tu sais que tu ne m'as pas être
complètement dévissée des perversités
gelée de jetons les oreilles à l'automne
sans trottoir ce que c'est a
manifestement un problème je pense que
c'est un art dans lequel tu excelles et
je pense que même la polémique au se
galvaniser